hey man oh hey how is it going
it's going great how are you i am great
i've um i've been suffering greatly
without our lessons i
i dropped 400 rating points i basically
dropped to your level
400 rating points what happened do you
find like hard drugs and
fall asleep playing the game or
something i did yeah every game i just
i couldn't stay awake after move two um
and so i forfeited on time game after
game after game
[Music]
okay so he's played a london system
which is a rare guest at
this level i've never seen this one and
normally when there's a rare guess like
this you just want to develop normally
um in fact most openings you want to
develop normally
now your favorite move would be a good
one if you look the point of his move is
to stop your bishop your light squared
bishop
from coming out to f5 right which is why
i'd want to just play the e4
um do you mean to g4 or to the knights
e4
the knight to e4 is what i was looking
at i think you don't even need to do
that because he might kick that knight
away with his pawn
uh now you could develop the c8 bishop
he's not deprived you of every square
yeah i still have g4 on the queen right
and he might launder his queen you know
you never know
right he's probably going to develop his
night out that's what usual london
players usually do
and um i don't okay wow he moved his
queen up
that's a pretty that's pretty good news
because that queen is going to be pretty
awkward
so what comes to mind oh well i
immediately just looked at playing the
e4
now but then he could just fork with the
pawn
that's what you're attacking but you're
attacking his queen but you're attacking
his queen so it's actually a very
interesting move
but after okay i'll just play and see
what happens yeah it's a little bit
dubious but
you know i'm trying to get you to play
on the edge a little bit you got to live
on the edge a little bit in chess
uh so if he reacts correctly this could
be suspicious
but okay he's moved to screen back now
he is threatening the fork
but you can you can prevent the fork i
mean you can move one of the two pieces
which piece do you think you can move
i was going to just go knight take on f2
oh wait yeah i was going to have a
[ __ ]
i i had a i had an idea for a follow-up
for when king takes on f2 but it's not
going to work so i'm not going to bother
uh i'll just drop i'm just going to drop
the picture back yep
perfect drop the bishop back to h5 and
notice that if he kicks your knight away
it looks like you've wasted time but in
playing f3 he's put a pawn on the square
where he normally wants to develop his
knight
so this is called this is sort of a
provocation you're
investing a little bit of time to you
know
ruin his position in a small way and
when you do a lot of that eventually his
he accumulates a lot of weaknesses that
you can then attack
if that makes sense makes sense to me
so he's definitely deciding right now
right this second wherever he is whether
to play f3 and chase your night away
he doesn't know what he's dealing with
obviously yeah
i wonder how has life been for you it's
been a little while anything
new uh it's been busy i'm you know i've
been working
on several non-streaming projects i was
working on a bunch of chess
youtube videos um i started working on a
new book
you know i started i actually was doing
a lot of
my own training um believe it or not
there's a lot of holes in my own game
that i was trying to patch off because
i'm anticipating that tournaments are
going to resume in a couple of months
well i mean who the [ __ ] knows when
anything is going to resume okay so he's
he's attacked d5 here you want to
reinforce that pawn
yeah so it was just going to be normal
development at e6 absolutely
and i was fixing some of the problems in
my own opening play
of which there are actually many believe
it or not do you play like one
are you known for like one particular
open um
somewhat somewhat so you can continue
developing normally here
i'm known for my aversion to
opening theory like i like taking the
game out of the beaten path
and going batshit crazy as early as
possible
now you could probably see well my style
is tremendously aggressive but you can
see how that could be a problem against
people who are very well prepared
right so you know sometimes if i'm on i
can beat anybody but i can also lose to
anybody and that's when you're a gm
trying to succeed that can be a problem
yeah i can see that i still think it's a
cool way of playing the game though
yeah i'm easily bored i mean that that's
what it stems from
so okay so you can continue developing
normally he's making a couple of moves
that might be mysterious to you but
they're
they're typical london moves so i was
just looking at taking that bishop
anyway with the knight
because then he stacks his pawns is that
even worth it
well once he's yeah that's fine that's
fine uh
what you're gonna see so you can do that
thank you boxer for the for the uh fat
ten gift subs as one as one likes to say
well so for that as the old as the old
expression yes so that's why
it's double-sided coin but you can drop
the bishop back
or you can defend the bishop
yeah so um what's better is it
is this position for the bishop even
very good should i
should drop it back h5 and let me
explain something
bring it back to g6 now he's going to
take your bishop i don't
i don't know why but i have a feeling he
will and then notice which pawn you
can't take with you'll have to take with
one particular pawn
yeah it's got to be f7 now you stack
your own pawns oh
wow my skills of prophetism have
abandoned me okay well that's good for
you now you can just continue developing
yeah i just want a castle indeed
but yeah the trend in top level chess
has been to play more and more solidly
i've kind of bucked that trend and i
like to play like they did in the 18th
century just
balls to the wall or nuts to the butts
you know
yeah yeah yeah i think that's the right
way of approaching you live
you live like you play chess oh okay i
don't exactly live like that
but i would hope not yeah
some chess players have the story the
stories i could tell
the insanity of chess players is unlike
the insanity of any
okay so g4 he's making aggressive
motions but he's not actually doing
anything
now here's the thing he's yeah go ahead
i'm just gonna say
i was going before i forgot the move i
immediately looked at with that was
going to e4
so then he can't push that g2 upon at
any point or he loses brooke
i like takes the middle back i like it a
lot
and you i think you unwittingly did
something interesting that's another
provocation move because he could push
his f1 out and chase your bishop
but again by pushing his fbon out he's
blocking the development of his own
knight and if he develops his knight to
f3 well then you have a bishop
established on an outpost
you see what i'm saying so it's it's
actually a very very good positional
move
and notice that he's not developed he
hasn't developed either of his knights
and what does that mean in the context
of what you what you want to do when the
center is closed
and he's not developing what do you want
to do to the center
i want to put as much pressure there as
possible you want to open it up yeah you
want to put pressure on the center you
want to open it up so that your pieces
have avenues toward his king
that's the way to punish people who
don't
you know other than a good old flogging
that's a good way to punish people
now he's played f3 so
what that opened up for me that i looked
at as a check on g3 with my bishop
that's awesome [ __ ] i didn't think you
would see that move i'm going to be
completely honest with you
that forces his king to move yeah and
that's that's an intermezzo that's an
intermediate move
and it's a good one now his king has no
castling rights anymore
damn sometimes you surprise me you know
i i have to confess
okay you have an absolutely sick move in
this position it is freaking
epic so look at his king look at his
king and his queen
what kind of position are they in
they're in a vault they're vulnerable to
one particular thing
two particular things what are they
they're on the same diagonal here
vulnerable to a bishop pin and they're
located on two adjacent squares which
means they can be picked off by what
other piece
potentially yes so they're forkable on
the b3 square you can combine both of
these with a sick tactic
forcing him to either get into a night
fork or open up a diagonal and get into
a bishop fork
let me see is what you're looking at uh
taking on d4
yes now that is why you play like a
madman moment so now just take right
here on d4
immediately and if he takes your bishop
you win the queen also
yeah that is pretty sick now he doesn't
have to do either in fact he shouldn't
but actually finding a way to get out of
the little tizzy he's found himself in
is pretty difficult
notice that you're also opening up the
center and doing so okay so he's
succumbed to the second of the traps
yeah bingo
yeah that is a cool spread of yeah
that's that was beautiful i noticed the
diagonal right away but i guess i didn't
think of a plan to get the pawn off i
like that but
it's also the forkable squares right
like the king and the queen that's how i
actually thanks bobster for the sub
that's actually how i
found this move is i noticed the king
and the queen are on d2 and c1 that's a
very common
forkable square a lot of games have been
won with a check with them
with a knight fork on b3
so okay now he's he's attending the
funeral of his lady
oh yeah this man's he is punching air
right now
he's grieving he's creating the loss of
your queen is um
it's like i don't know it's it's among
the most painful experiences
one could have gone off
thank you buffster appreciate it
yeah now he's got several he's got to
play king d1 because
at least he gets a bishop then for your
queen
if he moves the king out to c3 well
that's even worse
thanks all of you for the subs i really
appreciate it you go molly bobster
quizzical monk
no man he's just he's crying
i think we need to we need to send a
truck full of kleenex to him
yeah i mean he's just uh it looks like
he dc'd
well yeah i think he cries maybe we
should let him release the tension a
little bit
i'm pretty sure this man just unplugged
the router i think he just did
i don't talk about my router's right
under my feet the amount of times oh my
goodness he did unplug his [ __ ]
router yeah
no i told you that kind of very upset i
think
xfinity just experienced a nationwide
internet outage
or whatever they have
spectrum yeah we don't
we don't use that word around here
that's like voldemort's name that's oh
really
spectrum sucks well i actually have it
so i'm never talking to you again
actually i i don't like it i have random
internet out okay cool
thanks for that i thought you're gonna
say like you're sponsored by spectrum or
something i was gonna feel bad
no not at all no i i mean i would never
i would never sacrifice myself like so
let me yeah
okay i'm am i following you yes okay so
you're playing a new game against
ah yes of course tim oh [ __ ] i think you
should resign already
you're [ __ ] okay tim seems pretty
impressive man he's got a [ __ ] pool
noodle in there
he does i noticed that too okay so he's
playing the sicilian defense
and again you can develop normally but
you can also play what's called the open
situation you can push your d-pawn out
to
two to uh d4 and i think you've seen
this before
right and the point of that is that it
opens up the development for your bishop
and you're exploiting the fact that he's
remember he's not developing his pieces
he's pushing his pawns out
so therefore you're opening up the
center right
right no well he takes i take with
knight right i don't think with queen
yeah taking the queen would be the check
over variation um
check over was not a bad player but it
is a pretty adventurous line
everything has a name in chess even the
shittiest lines have a name
okay he's played the night or this is
the most popular sicilian
now take a look at both of your bishops
okay
do you see good development squares for
both of them and you can start with
either
um well he takes off the the free little
cheeky check which doesn't really do
much anyway so what i was looking at is
just the standard v4 for my f bishop
yep perfect that is the bobby fischer
variation
now i'll show you after this game i'll
blow your mind a little bit i'll show
you the amount of moves that white has
tried in that position it's actually
pretty
friggin interesting from right here the
bobby fischer
before bishop c4 so he's played e5 which
is a really bad positional move because
there is a certain square that he's
really weakened
now first you got to move your knight
and as you're moving it maybe you can
tell me what square that is
wow thanks gm bobby fischer for the bits
man i didn't even know his ghost is in
the chat
okay so where which square does the
knight want to go to and don't overthink
this i mean really any square is fine
i mean i could just drop it back to its
normal hold at f3
absolutely as you should now which
square has he weakened by playing e5
oh he can no longer put a pawn there on
the say the outpost at d5
right so immediately a plan has
crystallized now you don't want to put
the knight on d5 immediately because
he's got a knight on f6
guarding that square but we actually did
a training problem like this
what's your plan to get a knight to d5
how would you eliminate its defender
i just immediately go for an attack at
g5 with my baby
nice nice and this is a very typical
plan
actually in the sicilian defense i could
show you like 30 sicilian games
i can show you some of my games where
this happened okay continue
i just take the knight which frees up
the outpost bingo
now there's a phrase in chess the threat
is stronger than the execution
so you didn't have to put your knight on
d5 but here specifically there's no
reason not to
but sometimes there would be situations
where you'd want to hold out but we'll
talk about
talk about that afterwards so the
opening has been a success you're better
um over in far away australia
tim is yeah i don't know how that green
noodle is treating him right about now
i wonder how long people take to like
load up photos on their chest.com
accounts
like i still want to know i have a photo
from 2007
that is my profile but it's not very
intimidating but i am holding a trophy
up
oh yeah no i think it's intimidating i
mean i'm always intimidating okay so it
just could keep developing
yeah just a normal castle here yep just
a normal castle and this is going to be
a very instructive position because it's
going to allow you to find
a plan okay so he
some he wants to take your night but
that night will then be replaced by a
bishop
which will be just as good on that
outpost so that's it i don't need to
worry about that you don't need to worry
about that
you what you want to do is create a plan
and
does anything come to mind in terms of
what you want to start
working on in this position
hmm well the
the first thing that i wanted to do was
if i get my bishop there on d5 i wanted
to have my knight there on g5 as well so
i could come in with bishop take on f7
and win a rook but
i think that's a little too deep and
really reliant on things going
like the way i have it in my head
precisely
yeah so it's probably not a good plan um
other than that i was just going to get
this night off so i could look to maybe
do a rook lift
yeah i like that and you could open up
that f file potentially
so where would you put that knight on f3
where it's at least doing something
um i can't put it anywhere
on the g or h because bishop's guarding
both those and i can't take back so i
just have to bring it over here to d2
okay perfect yeah that's totally fine
and uh you want to open up that f5 with
f4 now
there's one thing you want to do before
you play f4 notice that after f4 e takes
f4
his bishop on f6 is going to be
attacking your b2 pawn
so before you play f4 what you want to
do is blunt his bishop like you want to
reduce its influence and then you'll be
ready to play up four without
sacrificing anything
yeah so i just want to push up the c
pawn exactly and
notice that you're also covering in
doing so the
d4 square so he can't put his knife his
own knight on an outpost
okay that makes sense then you're ready
to play for now
after the game i'll show you a couple of
alternative plans in that position which
you haven't yet really learned
so for all intents and purposes pushing
the f1 is a good plan
um okay plays b5 he chases your bishop
away no problem
yeah so i just bring it back it doesn't
change the plan mm-hmm
exactly now if he was really
professional he'd play knight a5 here
and try to take your bishop but i don't
know if that's within tim
341's capabilities
yeah so you want to play for you want to
open up that file not only do you want
to lift your rook up but
eventually you can foresee a future
right where you're attacking that pawn
on f7
yeah oh for sure so
yeah so we'll see what he's
what he's doing here
okay knight a5 he did play it
let me look at my stream viewers okay so
that doesn't technically stop you from
doing what you want to do
yeah it just comes at a higher cost now
because i'll lose bishop with the play
which is okay you know you can't always
have your cake and eat it too
well i think so i'm just going to push
up the f1 exactly
yeah in the style of bobby fischer he
would definitely approve
oh let's see if he takes your bishop i
mean what he's doing are very typical
moves that you play in the situation but
i'm impressed that he knows them okay so
what do you want to take with to
keep that outpost alive on d5
do uh i have to take with well
taking with the queen is the way that i
keep that alive isn't it
but then you pin yourself if you take
with a knight notice that your queen
then
defends the knight on d5 you open up the
defense of the queen
oh i see okay sorry do you want to take
with the knight yeah that's actually
part of the reason why it's good to put
the knight on t2 is now it's on b3 it's
guarding some of the queen side squares
um and it is well it's just doing a good
job overall he's got two bishops for two
nights but that's not always a good
thing
i actually like having two knights for
the two bishops
okay good yeah uh
i take with the pawn hold that right but
don't you want to outpost for your piece
if you take with the pawn it's like you
fill up the cavity you want you want to
keep
keep the cavity open do i take with the
queen here you want to talk about me
sorry for the dental reference but yeah
you want to take it it's fine that it's
out in the open because he's traded most
of his pieces
okay your queen has plenty of retreat
squares in case it'll be attacked
and so i want to just okay giving you a
check you know
you shouldn't be afraid of checks and
threats just because
they kind of exist you can always defend
against the threat yeah okay the only
difference here is just moving the king
back right
exactly and
your queen's actually very strong on d5
the queen's actually very strong here my
guess is he's gonna probably take your
pawn on f4 but maybe he'll want to keep
the f-file close i don't know
yeah he's definitely playing well but
but you're still better
let's see what he does yeah it's rare in
general that
somebody at his level plays the night of
sicilian
it's the kind of opening you normally
learn when you cross like 16 1700.
that's at least what was the case with
me
okay now he's given you the chance to do
something really cool
um you see that if he takes on f4 he
opens up
a file for his rook on e8 right yeah can
you prevent
all of that from happening could you
could you just freeze the king side
i just push up my pawn yeah and you
still have the capacity for a rook lift
so you've gained that ability
but you also freeze his rook and his
bishop look at how they're just staring
at that e5 pawn now doing absolutely
nothing
yeah so
now it's actually a very challenging
position to play but your long-term plan
can actually be a pawn storm on the king
side in addition to a rook lift
so when i say pawn strum what do i mean
is that a question that is our question
okay so i thought you're going to go
into like an explanation
so i'm assuming the next move in the
pawn storm would be pushing up to the g4
yeah okay it is and eventually you want
to prepare the move g5
which will chase this bishop away and
then perhaps g6 that'll be like a
checkmating move
now right you're ready to play g4
you're not ready to play g5 yet but
that's okay because you're going to
prepare that move that's where planning
comes in
do i need to worry about this pawn push
on a4 is that something i just wait on
do i want to preemptively get the knight
out or do i want to just wait
well i i would just wait i wouldn't
worry about it too much um
because your plan is stronger than his
and even if he plays a4 then you get
your night out to d2
okay so then just playing g4 now is the
right order
indeed so what you're learning right now
is not being afraid of like threats and
i totally understand the
instinct to prevent a threat is a good
one but you want to evaluate whether
something is actually dangerous now
here's the
mind-blowing thing you wanted to put
your knight on d2 anyway
because where is the knight going
ultimately and what is it going to do on
that final square
we're looking at f we're looking at f3
right he's helping you get where you
want
he's making it even easier exactly
because then you're going to be ready to
play g5
so this maneuver was something you were
going to embark on anyway
he's got only one actionable uh one spot
for that bishop right now right
bringing it to like e7 yeah well he
could put it on otherwise
f4 would be a pretty good square wow he
he knows what he's doing but now he's
allowed you to accomplish your plan
yeah i just play g5 anyway and you're
ready for
for real action now yeah
the bishop on f4 is actually on an
outpost because it's protected by the
pawn and it's hard to dislodge
it's like a splinter and you're behind
but
it's okay you know we can level the
splinter so is the queen on d5
now do you see why you're threatening g6
here
well i think yeah because you can only
take with one pawn which is this h pawn
which is going to open
up that for a rook lift right and then i
can look for like a mating maneuver
perhaps because he's
well he's trying to stop you from doing
that
and which is a good move
but what i would do here is just
generally improve your position you
don't always have to like
do something specific you have one piece
that's sleeping right now can you bring
it into the game
you're talking about my a rook here a1
yes
where would you put it
it means just any good square there's a
couple of good squares there's one open
file you can put the rook on
yeah so d1 is
doesn't seem terrible is that really the
best spot for it though it is
now your pieces aren't always going to
be conquering rome and
joining alexander the great on campaign
sometimes they're just occupying an open
file and supporting the queen that's
[ __ ] acceptable too um now the queen
on d5 is sort of the conqueror here but
the rook is just
sitting on a file where it's controlling
squares
so does that sort of make sense yeah
that makes sense
now you're basically tossing the ball
back into his court people don't like
deciding what to do
they want to be told what to do so he's
going to have a hard time here making a
decision about how to continue because
he's
okay he's gone queen e3 now you see that
rook on d1
you can employ it to chase that queen
away
yeah am i just bringing the rook to e1
now get the queen out exactly you get
the queen out
and you've done a little bit of
misdirection
insofar as you put it on d1 he's brought
his queen to an annoying square you're
like get the hell out of there
now you once he drops his queen back
assuming it's not on c5 which would be
the best move
i'm not anticipating he will play that
move though
now you can continue the pawn storm you
have one pawn that you haven't mobilized
yet
yes i want to push up to h4 yep get it
going
and then you actually are preparing a
sacrifice a breakthrough sacrifice you
see that pawn on g6 you want to get it
out of there so that you can play g6
right and you see how you can employ
that newly mobilized pawn to do that
yeah i'm just gonna throw it up at h5
yeah and that's a pretty minor sacrifice
because he's gonna end up with bad pawns
anyway
and um oh wow that is a weird move
yeah so that's just a free bishop yes
what do you want to take yep the knight
nice because you keep the queen in
outpost notice that you've opened up the
f file as a consequence
so what are you actually threatening
here
now i can just go right up there to f7 i
can just take pawn
open that up and go up to f7 immediately
right yes precisely you're threatening
to take the pawn wow
okay so by that token what do you want
to take here
did you keep the fight i want to take
take with the rook yeah
and then you have a typical idea once he
defends the pawn to reinforce your
attack on it
so he'll probably play rookie seven or
cafe
and then actually notice your prawns on
g5 and h5 well okay what comes to mind
i was just looking at stacking the rocks
do it okay
absolutely he's probably going to play
rook d7 here and now you need a new way
to attack that pawn you can use your
pawns
to prepare an idea you're familiar with
yeah was it is it pushing h5 and g6
okay precisely precisely you're ready to
play g6 and tear them apart
completely tear them apart watch your
clock a little bit once you get below a
minute you'll have to speed up but
what we're doing here okay now here's
the thing
he thinks he's defended against the
threat but he hasn't you just want to
tear the position open
which means g6 is still perfectly fine
you see what i'm saying you're just
opening up files for your rooks
i would pre-move hg okay
okay uh so now i just take with the pawn
here
and he can't take with a pawn if he
takes with a king well then he opens up
that g-file
for your rook um what he should do is
play f6
or he can give you a check on h8 which
is not scary at all
that's what i think he's going to do
he's probably going to give you a check
and in that case do i just want to
pre-move going to g2 because i'm pretty
sure that's how i'm
stopping that right well you don't want
to pre-move it because i'm not i'm not
positive that he's going to do that
well no i just met like if he does that
i just want to immediately go yeah right
yeah and he did so
so now in playing his rook to h8 he has
weakened his control he's probably going
to take the pawn on g6 with his pawn it
would be my guess
he's weakened his control over a square
into which you can then infiltrate
do you see that square is it f7 it is
because it's defended three times and
sorry it's attacked three times and
defended only twice
so that will signal the beginning of the
end
that will signal the beginning of the
end
yeah i mean there's really nothing else
you can do because okay
yeah i come in here with i come in here
with the rook he has to take with the
rook i take it back with the rook right
well you take back actually not with a
rook but there's a much better piece to
take back with oh
with the queen yeah with the queen here
now he's gonna go king h6
and here's the thing if he what is the
king's
only retreat square that's not along the
hp why is rook h1 not made
um
i actually don't oh because you can just
go to g5 can you employ one of our other
pieces
to cover it up how yeah so knight f3
bingo and essentially checkmate is
inevitable
um he can try to slither out of it but
if you play accurately it'll be made
okay well he didn't
try to slither out yeah so now just it's
just checkmate now at h1 yeah
yep perfect fantastic
okay so let me invite you to an analysis
board there's a lot to unpack there from
this game
um there were a couple of really
interesting moments he played very well
too
so good job okay
let me hope that this works
all right just invited you
nice that worked immediately wow i'm in
society is improving what can i say so
in this position this is the
start of the night or sicilian um
i can give you a sense here of how many
moves have actually been tried in this
position
so give me a second i'm actually loading
this on my other program where it tells
me
how many recorded games there were in a
particular position
okay it's searching right now
there we go so there were a total of
wow there's so many games that doesn't
even display it over
200 000 in this from this position so
bishop
bishop g5 is the most popular move with
74 000 games
then let me just list the amount of
moves that have more than 100 games
played with them
here we go bishop g5 bishop b3 bishop e2
bishop c4
f3 f4 h3 g3 a4 bishop d3 rook g1 queen
f3 knight b3 a3 h4 queen e2 knight f3
queen d3
so i followed a couple of those yep and
the funny thing is
uh a couple of years ago i was
playing a tournament pretty big
tournament the us championship and i
wanted to find something new in this
position
so just from the amount of moves that i
read out you can probably guess how hard
that is
right but i did manage to find a move
that by that time
in that time like this was like two
years ago was extremely rare
and it's become a lot more popular since
since then which is the move h4
and basically the idea is to
preemptively start off a pawn storm on
the king side because i'm so sure that
he's gonna castle short at some point
i'm already kind of beginning that pawn
storm
if that makes sense okay yeah i get you
but
mostly i was doing that for the
creativity points that's just to give
you a flavor of how crazy i am
oh yeah real wacko that's nice though h4
i know
immediately send me off to the mental
institution when they found out i played
that move
yeah going right to oracle with that
kind of [ __ ] the psychiatrists were
lined up at the door on the yeah
so anyways bishop c4 is one of the
classical moves
uh bobby fischer basically pioneered it
now what would be black's best move here
you know that this bishop is controlling
this diagonal
can black basically blunt the bishop's
control over that diagonal
yeah just going e6 just going e6 would
be absolutely correct
um so he's played e5 you dropped your
knight back bishop g5 bishop takes f6
and knight t5 now this plan should make
perfect sense you we've seen it several
times before
and rookie 8 castles bishop e6 is great
now you came up with the idea of opening
up that f-file potentially lifting a
rook up
um i actually while i was in the
bathroom i remembered a story i wanted
to share with you
um and i forgot to share it and it
relates to the night or so do you still
see the analysis board
this is now when i say night or that's
not some mythical
you know like sumerian word
it's it's actually after all most
openings are named after someone naidorf
was a grandmaster miguel nadorf
uh from poland he was a strong player in
his own right and he just developed this
line
in fact the first person to ever play
the night arth
and usually it's not the person it's
named after it was a guy named
pierce halawa in 1899 wow
was only like the 30th to play the night
or
it's just that he put the most effort
into it and then the second person
believe it or not somebody played this
in 1899 and then the next time somebody
played it was 1926 it took 27 years
before somebody actually played this
line again
um anyways so a couple of years ago i
taught
a camp to some very high rated kids
i don't remember if i shared this before
so they were you know two thousand
twenty one hundred really good players
right
and i was talking about the night off
and i was explaining some of its
intricacies and i managed to convince a
room full of 2100 rated kids because i'm
really good at pranking them
and because i usually have a serious
face even though i'm just
[ __ ] trolling all the time uh i
convinced him that the move bishop f4
had been a recent theoretical novelty oh
yeah you told me this i told you that i
did totally
yeah so those of you who are new yep i
basically managed to do that despite the
fact that black can win a piece
and believe it or not bishop f4 has been
actually played 34 times
out of 200 000 that's not super super
yeah but
amazingly like a 2000 played it i seen
1800 played it
so i don't know what went through these
people's minds
um when they probably took your class
yeah they probably
those are all of the kids in my class i
can see the names yes people like
alvarez moreno and gelbanegger and um
to feng gian man i'm telling you like
the names of chess players you cannot
make that [ __ ] up it's like only chess
players have those names
okay um anyways back to business
so all right
so bishop e6 um and this was the
position
where you prepared the movement of your
half point
now what catches my eye here when i'm
looking at this is this d6 pawn you
notice that it's weak
correct now
well the problem is that you have a
knight on d5 that's blocking
that's blocking the queen's axis to that
pawn
so here's what i'm thinking what i'm
going to do is i'm going to preemptively
pile up on this pawn
step one and then step two
when i'm ready i'm going to move this
knight away from d5
and i'm going to expose the attack on
the d-pawn
okay could you propose a way to pile
up when i say pile up on the d-pawn what
the hell do i mean
well put more attackers on the deep one
more how would you do that
um without moving the knight right we
need to keep the night on that outpost
we need to keep the night on the outpost
to patch things up before we're ready to
expose it
so what i look at is the most obvious
one which is just bringing a pawn up to
it so you drop the bishop back and push
up that pawn but then that just
hangs upon and then that's not really
that great right
don't confuse attacking the weakness
with like with like eliminating it right
because you technically attack it if you
put a pawn on c5 but you will
also allow black to get rid of it so you
actually do need to use your pieces
okay i'm not expecting this to be easy
because this is the first time that i've
shown you this type of plan
so so is it
queen d2 and then put a rook
on d1 then bring queen to b4 now you've
introduced two new attackers and you're
still attacking other pieces like you're
now attacking b7 with queen
yes that's absolutely that's a great
plan so queen d2 would be the start
let's say a black play something random
now first of all you put a rook here and
then you would put a queen on b4 that's
exactly what i was thinking
that's plan number one i'll show you a
second idea now let me tell you
one other thing which is that you don't
even always need to put a queen on
on b4 so let's say black develops his
knight you drop your bishop back to a
protected square
and black plays a random move what are
you now ready to do
um we're ready to move the knight and
attack that pawn right
and where would we move it where would
we move it so that it's
as forcing as possible
remember chess is a game of tit protect
like you want to give up some advantages
and get certain others so you don't want
to get emotionally attached to
any of your pieces i know you tend to do
that a lot you cry over your knights and
bishops
but you got to get rid of themselves
right
sometimes you wait for them
so we need to force it right so what i'm
looking at is bringing knight to b4
is that the right play for it that's a
good move that is a good move but it's
not forcing enough because i move my
bishop back
and guess what the pawn is now protected
i think that your brain is is
exiting out this move because even
though you don't think you like this
knight you like it more than you think
you do
but you can take a piece here is it just
taking the bishop
but the point is not that you don't want
to take the bishop it's just you have to
in order to force black's hand and now
you're ready to win a pawn
okay and now you might be like all of
this [ __ ] to win a single goddamn
pawn you have anything
better for me well that's just the
nature of grand master level chess like
you do all of the stuff you went upon
and a pun
is something to celebrate you know what
i'm saying like at the high level
a pawn is a pretty big deal right yeah i
could definitely see that
which brings me to the second plan um
and i'll show you why i know this
i actually everything i know most things
that come from games that i lost
um and i was able to learn from really
good players what to do in these types
of positions
chances are for every position that
you've had i had a pretty similar type
of position and
in fact i'll show you that this is the
case with this position too here's what
white could do
you notice that this knight on d5 is
exerting overall pressure on black's
position
now what you could do is you could
basically say i'm not going to play on
the king side i'm going to play on the
queen side
i'm going to attack this b7 pawn and i'm
just going to start pressuring his queen
side
and in order to attack a pawn you first
need to immobilize it
this pawn on b7 as tim34341 showed you
can go out to b5 can you stop that pawn
from going to b5
yeah i just play a4 bingo that's a great
first move
now can you devise a way um using one of
the pieces that's not currently doing
anything to apply pressure on the b7
tone
do i just do i rook lift up a3
absolutely
[ __ ] lutely and i was hoping you
would say that you see that not all rook
lifts
are tactical some rook left are
positional um
i actually wrote an article called the
positional rook lift a couple years ago
precisely on these types of little rook
lifts i love them
okay i don't love them like i love i
don't know
hamburgers and cookout but um
and when you have an affinity for them i
get you i have an affinity i have a mild
affinity for them okay it's not a
yeah i want to be very clear about what
it is here what it is what it isn't
i'm not going to kink shame you i mean
it's fine man yeah right exactly thank
you thank you
you got my hands excellent uh so rook a3
rook b3
and this causes more discomfort to block
than it might seem
okay because we're gonna make a couple
empty moves for black
um once you play rook b3
not only do you attack this one first of
all it's pretty [ __ ] hard to defend
because if black tries to defend it with
his queen what move do you now have
well i mean there's if you take bishop
it's a check you force the pawn
that's true but you have something a lot
juicier here
this is something you used to miss a lot
oh jesus i see it yeah it's a different
fork it's over on b6
it is and you want to be very precise
here let's say he brings his queen out
to c6
you don't want to take the rook
immediately because you lose your bishop
so what do you want to do first
i would need to reinforce the bishop so
you would want to somehow do that with
with tempo right you don't want to move
your queen out and defend it because
he's going to have time to move his rook
out so you're right that you want to
reinforce it
but you have a way of reinforcing it
such that you're also attacking an
opponent's piece
okay is it
[Music]
it's a really strong move
is it just bringing the bishop to b5
you're close then his pawn can take the
bishop
but then you oh i see yeah but you get
an exchange
and you can win an entire rook here
you're right your idea is exactly right
it's just not b5 there's a different
square
d5 then right bingo that's a very strong
move
takes takes you're attacking his queen
your attacking truck now the simpler
thing to do would have been just to take
his bishop
and i noticed that sometimes you have an
aversion to just taking pieces or
trading i think you still have that a
little bit
and sometimes it holds you back just a
little bit there's nothing wrong with
trading
inherently especially because here black
has to choose between giving up his rook
or not recapturing the bishop both of
which are equally disastrous
okay does that make sense that makes
sense so both moves would be fine
and so that would be the other plan in
this position that you could exploit so
the last thing is i'll show you how i
know this
again i know it's a big problem to copy
games into the analysis board so let's
see if you can actually see this once i
copy it in
let's say say your freaking prayers
crash your computer again okay i just
pasted it
um yeah no i don't do you see let me let
me look at your stream
i'm looking position did change it did
but again it's that
ghostly problem where you're literally
i'm moving pieces and it's moving in a
different board for you
so let me um let me copy the game
into a different analysis board if that
doesn't work we'll just skip that part
i was just gonna show you a very similar
game that i played
which taught me a lot about how to play
these types of positions i wanted to
show you how the progression works
of improvement okay so let me try this
pgn i wonder why this doesn't work i'm
actually going to write a note right now
i've been procrastinating with that
okay i'm reinviting you so you can close
that other board okay
okay now let's see what you see i swear
to god i'm going to break something if i
see
the wrong game playing oh my god again
this is this was a game it was like this
was a game i played yesterday against uh
actually world number four very strong
player i played a match with him
yesterday
nice and but but that but that's not the
[ __ ] game i wanted to show you okay
so fine
uh last attempt i'm gonna copy a
position
that's definitely gonna close the board
again i'm really sorry to make you do
this
it's all good man um
and what i'm gonna do is is actually
just copy a position
and this should actually work okay
yeah who would have thought i'm actually
copying in a game doesn't work okay just
invited you
um and by the way speaking of
interesting names
perfect you see the position the guy i
played yesterday world number four his
name is yad napomnishi
which is not only unpronounceable it
means it means in russian
one who doesn't remember now he has
actually a fantastic memory which is the
funny part
that's a cool [ __ ] name though it is
lachesta so lachesta's q is his
chess.com name but his real name is
jan upon okay so this is a game i had
the black pieces here do you see the
similarity in the opening
yeah you see the bishop on this diagonal
you see i have played e5
and my opponent in this game was a grand
master by the name of sergey kudrin
he was a russian grand master and
oh [ __ ] now my computer has okay don't
froze uh and this was played in 2009
in philadelphia as if anybody gives a
[ __ ] about where it was played but i
have to say it you know it's good for
him
um as if if this game was played in
chicago it would be any different
okay so the great thing about chess is
that once you play a game you can
generalize ideas to other games so
when you think about what you did in
your game can you find
a good planet here for white
okay so with the similarities the d6
pawn is still pretty weak since it can't
be reinforced by a pawn
it only has the bishop on it right now
so what else is one attacker
um beautiful
i had to bring the level of conversation
down at some point okay i'm sorry
oh it's all good man i didn't think you
heard me that's a good mic i just
i just like whispered that damn i hear
everything i'm damn near omniscient
cover blown okay so you did this thing
in your game
and he did this thing in this game it's
literally exactly the same plan
before we attacked the pawn on d6 what
did you do
well i in my game or in what we just
went over
um in your game well i know you ate
breakfast this morning but what did you
do in your game
before you before you attacked before
you could have attacked the pawn on d6
i prepped it so i what piece did you put
on what square
in other words you put a knight on an
hour where's that outpost
yeah i put the knight on d5 bingo so how
can you prepare that how did you prepare
that in your game
sorry to be so pushy about this i think
it's just important to see how this
generalization works
no all good um well my game i had the
bishop uh
guarding it i had the pawn on it which
both things are here right now
but before you put it if before you put
the knight on d5 you eliminated
one of its defense oh i took out the
knight oh yeah okay
yeah so we take out the knight so the
knight can't take back so what do we do
specifically
we're going g5 with the [ __ ] okay you
can actually go ahead and play that
just mostly to test whether it works
yeah bishop g5 is exactly what he played
i went knight p4 you see that i'm trying
to reinforce my control over that square
with the other knight
kudrin takes on f6 now you see why you
know it's a gm but
you see why he's doing what he's doing i
took his bishop
he took i took now here's the five head
thing
i can't he can take my pawn on d6 but he
actually didn't
because he was so enamored with the idea
of putting a knight on d5 as he should
have been that he thought it was even
better
than taking this pawn on d6 and opening
up diagonals for my bishops
so what move do you think he did play
here
he played c3 with his knight he did
and i want to ask you to find one more
move that occurs in just a couple more
moves so bishop c4 attacking his queen
he drops his queen back
queen c6 he forces my bishop back and
now he makes a real 500 gm move
now what would be the problem with
putting the knight on d5
two attackers only one or well yeah
only one defender this is called one
defender pot on e4
is one defender i would say that's two
defenders wouldn't you
yeah yeah so um
is there a reason he can't play that am
i looking for the reason why he can't
just immediately go to it there's a
specific reason he can't go to d5
and this is one of the hard things about
chess is you're tunnel visioning the
square you're thinking you're assuming
that there's something going on on this
square but in reality white has
relinquished his control
over another square um that can now be
exploited
black look at the whole thing i see is
that
b2 pawn yeah but a pawn is upon as
as as richard jay nixon once said upon
his pawn is upon
um bishop takes d5 rook takes d5 queen
c2 but why would you just give up upon
when you cannot give up the pun right
i feel like in your mind you're thinking
of ponza's disposable i told you that
but disposable doesn't mean you want to
just give them away for free
does that make sense so my opponent made
a really really nice move
he prepares to move knight t5 by
preliminarily defending this pawn
and using once again a piece that's not
currently doing anything in order to do
that
what movement he just he brings rook to
a2 right bingo
bingo and now he's ready for knight t5
and he crushed me because later on
through the left through the errors that
i'm drawing the rook rejoined the defile
and he actually ended up winning the
game by attacking the d6 spawn and
playing on the queen side
so all of these similarities led me to
form my opinion about how white should
play in these positions you see
and i found a lot of games where i got
crushed a lot
because of a weakness on the d5 square
that's one of the main drawbacks of the
night off actually
anyway sorry i feel like i talked
forever but you get the point
no i'll be bad okay so my idea now
because you know just to
sort of get you back and forth was to
solve a couple of puzzles but to
actually solve a couple of
more challenging puzzles than you're
used to and perhaps we can talk through
a couple of new
tactical thinking patterns while we're
doing that what do you say to that
but if you want to play more that also
is totally fine with me
no that sounds good to me real quick
though i see chad keep playing
c1 for the rook and i think that i think
the reason why you don't play c1 is
because you can just attack with the
bishop and then you're
you're kind of [ __ ] you have to go
back and then you're exactly right now
he can't attack with the bishop
immediately why
yeah because you have the knight on it
but you can just easily stop that right
because you push up the h pun
yeah so first of all you could push up
the h pawn prepare for g5 excellent now
second of all
you don't want to be in a situation
where one of your pieces is behold it is
tied to a particular square you want the
knight to have mobility
and the knight doesn't have mobility
what if you wanted to bring the knight
to e3 and then to d5 well you couldn't
do that because
if if if you ever play knight t2 well
there's a very annoying bishop g5 move
so that's exactly the reason why
rook is better on a2 than on c1 very
nicely okay cool
yeah bobby this game was against sergey
kudrin grandmaster
[Music]
you